(audience cheering)
(upbeat soul music)
♪ I know a place, mmm ♪
♪ Ain't nobody cryin' ♪
♪ Ain't nobody worried ♪
♪ Ain't no smilin' faces, mmm, mmm ♪
♪ Lyin' to the races ♪
♪ Help me ♪
♪ Mmm, help me ♪
♪ Come on ♪
♪ Help me ♪
♪ Somebody help me ♪
♪ I'll take you there ♪
♪ Oh, I'm gonna take you there ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ I'll take you there, oh, yeah ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Ooh, mmm, mmm, mmm ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Oh, come on now ♪
♪ Come on now ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Oh, mercy now ♪
♪ I'll take you there ♪
♪ Oh, baby, I'll take you there ♪
♪ Oh, oh, if you're ready ♪
♪ Come on now ♪
♪ I'll take you there ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, come and go with me now ♪
♪ I'll take you there ♪
♪ Ain't nobody, ain't nobody cryin' ♪
♪ I'll take you ♪
♪ Ain't nobody worried ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ I'll take you there ♪
♪ And there ain't no smilin' faces ♪
♪ Mercy, mercy, hey ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)